Welcome, everyone. Thank you for coming for a late in the day session.
My name is Ben Schlechter. I'm a GI medical oncologist at the Dana-Farber Cancer
Institute, and my research focuses on immunoeffector cell therapies and GI
malignancies in solid tumors. And we have a great session today, and behalf of
my co-chair, we would like to thank you for attending.
We're going to cover a broad spectrum of topics, everything from novel delivery
of CARs, arming of CARs, mature
data on uveal melanoma, two different oncotropic viruses, one for HCC and
another for pancreatic cancer, and a lipid nanoparticle delivery system,
sort of an in vivo light rather than CAR, which I think is a fascinating
launch to a new era in oncology here. So...
Okay. Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Ling Shen from Peking University Cancer Hospital.
I'm a medical oncologist focused on the GI cancer and early stage
trial. And recently, we also focused on the
cell therapy. Thank you.
Perfect. So I'd like to invite up Dr.
Joan Chu, who'll be giving us a discussion of a phase one trial of intraperitoneal
mesothelin-targeted CAR T therapy in patients with mesothelin-positive
esophageal and gastric cancers with peritoneal carcinomatosis. Thank you.
Hi. Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Joan. I'm from Singapore.
I'm a medical oncologist, but I spent a year at MSK, and
I'm very grateful for the opportunity to present our findings from a phase
one trial of intraperitoneal mesothelin-targeted
CAR T cell therapy in patients with mesothelin-positive esophageal gastric
cancer with peritoneal carcinomatosis.
Here are my disclosures.
So a key takeaway point is that intraperitoneal mesothelin-targeted
CAR T cell administration was safe.
CAR T persistence was noted in the peripheral blood beyond
day 100.
Antitumor activity in mesothelin-positive esophageal gastric
adenocarcinoma was limited, and this is likely reflecting the
heterogeneous target expression.
Given the safety data that we observed and the higher level of mesothelin
expression in peritoneal mesothelioma, we are amending the
study to recruit such patients in future.
So the background is that peritoneal carcinomatosis occurs in up to
40% of esophageal gastric adenocarcinoma and
has very poor survival outcomes and resistance to systemic treatment.
Mesothelin is overexpressed in up to 60% of esophageal gastric
adenocarcinoma and associated with very aggressive disease biology in
stage four patients, and we know that mesothelin has low levels of
expression in normal tissues.
Our group designed M28 Zeta-1XXPD1-DNR, which is an
autologous mesothelin-targeted CAR, which features a
CD28 costimulatory domain as well as a modified CD3
zeta and a PD-1 dominant negative receptor which lacks an
intracellular signaling domain, and this provides intrinsic
checkpoint blockade to the CAR T cells.
Here we have data from our preclinical studies,
where we have orthotopic mouse model
which mimics human peritoneal carcinomatosis
and manifests with ascites as well as bowel obstruction.
And we can see that regional delivery of the mesothelin-targeted CAR T
cells conferred better efficacy as well as survival outcomes
compared to systemic delivery of higher doses of the same CAR T cells in
these mice.
Our group has also previously demonstrated that regional intrapleural
delivery of a previous generation of M28 Zeta
mesothelin-targeted CAR T cells in combination with systemic
anti-PD-1 therapy with pembrolizumab was safe and efficacious in
patients with pleural disease.
So in this study, it was a phase one study assessing the safety,
maximum tolerated dose, and preliminary efficacy of
IP-administered mesothelin-targeted CAR in patients with mesothelin
positive defined as more than 25% positive by
immunohistochemistry with evidence of peritoneal
carcinomatosis.
And here we have the study schema. So patients had to have
peritoneal disease on imaging and/or cytology, had to have
received at least one prior line of therapy, and these patients were screened for
mesothelin positivity.
Patients underwent leukapheresis, and we needed three to four weeks for cell
production. During this time, patients were allowed to have bridging
chemotherapy, and subsequently, they underwent liver depletion and
received the IP-administered CAR T cells.
These patients were monitored for at least two days inpatient and subsequently
discharged to outpatient follow-up.
Here we have the primary objectives, again, as mentioned earlier, and we have the
dose escalation scheme based on the continual reassessment method.
And we started at dose level two with dose of three times ten to power six
cells per kilogram.
We screened 54 patients, and of these, 19 were positive
and eligible for enrollment. And to date, we have treated seven patients with
IP-administered CAR.Here we have the baseline
characteristics of the seven patients that we treated, and we can see
that they had good performance status.
All patients had peritoneal disease, and some patients had extra-peritoneal
disease at baseline. In patients with significant
ascites at baseline, this was drained prior to the IP administration of the
CARs.
And we can see that these patients were also quite heavily treated.
Most of them received between three to five prior lines of therapy.
Most patients had immunohistochemistry 3+, which corresponds to
75% positivity of mesothelin.
We can see the best response was stable disease in several patients,
and progression-free survival as stated, which I will go into greater detail in a
future slide.
Here we have the treatment emergent adverse events, and we can see that
most patients
developed low-grade CRS, and this was early in onset,
and it resolved quickly with a single dose of administration of tocilizumab.
In patient seven, there was a relatively late onset to the fevers at
day 14, but again, this resolved with tocilizumab.
However, this same patient developed recurrence of the fevers five days later,
as well as severe transaminitis, hyperferritinemia, and
coagulopathy, and this was consistent with IE-CHS.
Fortunately, the patient responded very quickly to high-dose
dexamethasone, enokinura, as well as one dose of
ampel 马 , and the toxicity resolved within about four
days.
We did not see any neurotoxicity in this trial, and there was no
pleuritis or pericarditis observed.
We did see low-grade abdominal pain in most patients, which we thought
was a on-tumor, on-target effect.
We also saw grade three pharyngitis in patient seven,
and we also thought that this was due to
an off-tumor, on-target effect, as there's mesothelin expression in the
tonsillar epithelium.
Most patients had low-grade GI toxicity, which was easily managed.
There was no dose-limiting toxicity that we saw and no grade five
adverse events.
And here we have the SUMILs plot showing the survival outcomes.
So three patients had stable disease by RECIST.
However,
they developed clinical progressive disease requiring
palliative radiotherapy for symptoms that did not correspond to worsening
radiological findings.
Here we have the RECIST responses for patient seven, where we
saw tumor shrinkage in the target lesions.
However, the patient had disease progression elsewhere, for example, lymph
nodes,
and we hypothesized that this is due to heterogeneous target antigen
expression.
Here we have the vector copy number showing that the CAR-T
expansion peaked around day 25 to day 30
and showed that there was CAR-T persistence beyond 100 days in
our patients.
So in conclusion, intraperitoneal mesothelin-targeted CAR T cell
administration was safe. CAR-T persistence was noted in the peripheral
blood beyond day 100.
Antitumor activity in mesothelin-positive esophageal gastric adenocarcinoma was
limited, and we believe that this is likely reflecting heterogeneous
target expression.
I'd like to thank all the patients and their families, the research
staff, clinical team, AVERSYS unit, and investigators.
The funding came from the US Department of Defense and was also partially
supported by the Esophageal Cancer Education Fund.
Thank you for listening. Happy to take any questions.
I can start with a question while we wait for some from the audience.
So I note that you have the dominant negative PD-1 signaling, which I think is a
really clever idea, and we've seen that in a few other cases.
As a predictive biomarker, is mesothelin plus CPS score,
for example, necessary to result in activation and persistence of the CAR, or
is it truly mesothelin, and is it PD-L1 independent?
In our study, the PD-L1
expression did not seem to predict for better responses to the
mesothelin-targeted CAR.
Yeah. But our previous study in pleural disease showed that
combination with anti-PD-1 therapy in pleural mesotheliomas seemed to
confer better responses as well as durability, and that
was why we built in this dominant negative decoy receptor.
We have a-
A nice trial. There is a huge variation of the cellular
composition of the malignant ascitis from gastric cancer.
So do you think that some patients may have very
much M2 macrophages in the ascitis, while some
patients might have tumor-rich ascitis?
So the cellular composition may affect the
efficacy of your intraperitoneal delivered CAR T?
Yeah. So we are conducting translational correlative studies looking
at the ascitic fluid as well as the on-treatment tumor
biopsies to evaluate this further to see what was driving
the resistance to the
treatment that we gave.
We have another question at the microphone.
Very nice study.
You had quite a range in the PK,
and patient seven had, it looks like, by far the highest Cmax,
but also the IE-CHS.
Do you know any characteristics of the circulating cells in that patient?
Did more CD4, CD8 CAR, or why?
And did they have any off-target
toxicity you could see?
Yeah. So that same patient developed that grade three pharyngitis that I
mentioned, which we thought was an on-target, off-tumor
toxicity. In terms of the other dynamics of the cell
types, we haven't had a chance to look at that yet.
But we did see that the absolute lymphocyte count was very, very high as well,
probably corresponding to the peak in the CAR T expansion at the same time.
So
if I
remember correctly, Prasad published this
probably same CAR T.
In that case, it was intrapleural local regional delivery.
Maybe that study also used PD-1 as a combination.
They published in the "Cancer Discovery." But this one,
the tumor response looked to be a
little less impressive than what was observed in the
case of intrapleural. Well, of course, it's different tumor
indication, but can you comment on this one?
We believe that's because that was in pleural mesothelioma.
In that study, the majority of the patients actually had 90% to 100%
positivity for mesothelin. Our study used a much lower cutoff of
25%. And also we know that pleural and
peritoneal mesothelioma express mesothelin in a much more
homogeneous way compared to gastric cancer, where we expect
a much more heterogeneous expression.
So that's why we believe that the
anti-tumor activity was more modest in this trial.
Okay. I have a question about your study.
You used the
IP infusion, you will avoid the plenary
injury, but the efficacy is quite
lower. How to increase
this efficacy in the future?
One issue is probably maybe
in this particular tumor type with the heterogeneous expression, there's
maybe several other clones that do not have the target.
And we know from preclinical data that the cells
traffic to only mesothelin positive.
For example, in the mouse model, you only traffic to the flank tumors which were
mesothelin positive, and not to the flank tumors that were negative.
So it's very target specific.
In terms of how to improve, we do think that regional delivery is still better
than systemic delivery if the target is correct, and if the tumor burden is
in the regional area where you're delivering the CAR T cells to.
So,
perhaps it's just about selecting the right tumors that respond to the appropriate
product.
Excellent, thank you. So I think we can move on to our next talk.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So next up we have Dr. Changsong Qi talking about the safety and
preliminary efficacy of a novel Lego-STIM armored mesothelin-targeted CAR
T therapy in advanced solid tumors.
Thank you for kindly introduction.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Dr.
Changsong Qi, a medical oncologist from Peking University Cancer Hospital
2.
It's my great honor to stand here to talk about the safety and the
preliminary efficacy of a novel Lego-STIM armed
mesothelin-targeted CAR T cell therapy in advanced solid tumor.
This is my disclosure.
UCMYM802 is a CAR T
product prepared by MRA
electroporation protocol process.
Mainly consists of two parts. One part is about the CAR
including anti-mesothelin ScFv and the
4-1BB costimulatory domain. And another
important part is Lego-STIM, which
including
extra membrane CD14 and the intra membrane CD28,
which will let our CAR T cells
enhance the ability of the
inhibitory effect of the tumor
microenvironment T cells, and enhance the killing function
and the persistence of the CAR T cells, and improve the suppressive tumor
microenvironment from cold to hot, and
simultaneously enhance adaptive immunity and innate immunity,
and then enhance the body's immunity against the tumors.
The study objectives, including the primary objective, which is to evaluate
the safety and the tolerability of
UCMYM802 and to
determine the MTD and the RP2D. And the secondary objectives,
including to characterize the pharmacokinetics
and to evaluate the pharmacodynamic, to
assess the immunogenicity, and to investigate the
preliminary efficacy, and to determine the
positive threshold of the mesothelin expression, and to
explore the immune response process.
Let's walk through the study design.
As the logic of MRA-based CAR T therapy are
quite distinct from the conventional or retrovector CAR T.
After informed consent, eligible patients with advanced
mesothelin-positive solid tumor undergoes screening.
Once confirmed, patient proceeds to apheresis to collect the
PBMC. And unlike the traditional CAR T, which take weeks
to months,
our
CAR T product is manufacturing using GMP compliant
MRA electroporation.
This process will take three to four weeks.
And different from the traditional CAR T cell therapy, the patients
enrolled in this study will not need the lymphodepletion
chemotherapy. They will directly
undergo the infusion of the CAR T cells at the
day zero, day seven, day 14, and the day
21.And then undergo the follow-up until months
24 and at schedule visits during long-term survival.
And the response evaluation is per RECIST 1.1.
And there are three dose levels in this clinical trial.
The first dose level is about 100 million cells,
and the second is 500 million cells, and the
third is about 1 billion cells.
This slide is about the patient characteristics.
We can find that we enrolled
some
subtypes of the solid tumor, including the peritoneal
malignant
mesothelioma, pancreatic cancer,
cholangiocarcinoma, pancreatic cancer, ovarian cancer, and the lung
adenocarcinoma. And the median prior lines of therapy is three.
We can find that they
are the very heavily pre-treated patient.
And
the seven patients received the full infusion cycles and two
patients received
just one infusion cycle.
Let's move on to the safety profile.
The most common treatment-related adverse events during the
study was cytokine release syndrome, fever,
decreased lymphocyte count, anemia,
prolonged prothrombin time, and hypotheria.
And in this clinical trial, one patient experienced
a grade four
cytokine release syndrome with hypotension at 1 billion cell
dose level, which are defined of DRT.
And
two patients suffered grade three or higher
cytokine release syndrome.
In nine patients received at least one cycle of infusion,
and seven were evaluable for efficacy.
Among these evaluable patients, the objective response rate
was
28.6%, and the disease control rate was
57.1%, with two patients achieving partial response.
And notably, patient five sustained
progression-free survival for more than 12 months.
And at
500 million cell or higher dose level,
the objective response rate was
33.3%.
Because this is an mRNA-based CAR T product, the PK
profile is very distinct from the
retrovector-based CAR T cells, as shown here.
Among patients receiving multiple infusions, the CAR copy number
peaks approximately one hour post
infusion and began to decline significantly after eight hours.
The highest expansion was
consistently seen after the first infusion cycle.
And consist with the PK data,
the peak value of the K cytokine, particularly interferon gamma,
aligns closely with the timing of the
peak CAR T copy number. This
rapid on and off kinetic profile is the
hallmark of the
transient nature of mRNA CAR T.
Importantly, we observed a positive correlation between dose
level, the CAR T express, and the Lego expression
levels. This confirms that even with the transient CAR expression,
the biologic activity is dose dependent and
measurable.
This is perhaps the most important translational research in this
clinical trial. We
do the spectral flow or cytometric analysis of the
T cells, NK cells, and the DC cells in the collected
blood samples from the patient five, seven, eight, and nine.
And compared to other three patients, the objective response rate
patient file can show the increased central memory T
cells in CD8 positive T cells, decreased highly
differentiation T cells expression, KLRG1,
and CD57. And we can find that in the patient
file, increased the tumor reactive T cells expressing
CD103, CD39,
CX3CR1, and TM3. And we can also find
the increased NK and mature NK cells,
decreased NKT cells, and increased
CDC1 and CDC expressing XR1.
Conclusions. UCMY-IMH02,
a novel Lego stimula-armed mesothelin-targeted CAR T
demonstrates tolerable safety in the
first-in-human phase 1 trial and demonstrates
preliminary efficacy signal in mesothelin-positive peritoneal
tumors and cholangiocarcinoma. And despite the
low express and persistence of mRNA-based CAR T cells,
the Lego stim molecule may enhance the body's
innate immunity against the tumor and to maintain
long-term anti-tumor activity.
That's all. We must thank the patients and their families participated in
this clinical trial, and all the
collaborators and colleagues. Thank you for your attention.
Excellent. Thank you. We have a question on the side.
Hi. Frank of Columbia. Can you explain or do you have a hypothesis why the
mRNA exposure decreases in your PK with repeated
dosing?
Yeah. This is a
very important question.
Exactly, I don't know the exact reason, but I
think maybe some,
like ADA or the
immunogenicity can make
important role in this decrease in the multiple
infusion. Thank you.
Have those ADA assays been performed yet?
Yeah.
And just to clarify, was there any lymphodepletion even before cycle one,
or was this totally un-lymphodepleted?
Yeah.
There was no lymphodepletion?
I wonder, would you speculate the lymphodepletion may actually
improve
the ADA process?
Maybe.
And I concern about two patients
have a response rate and one patient with a longer,
PFS more than nine months.
Do you think which is more potent to selection of patients?
How to selection the right patient?
I think there may be some important aspect.
One is the tumor burden. The less the tumor burden,
the more benefit we will achieve. And
another is about the expression of the
mesothelin.
We can find that the most benefitor
with mesothelin H score is very, very high.
Yeah, I think
right now is the most important aspect we can
do to
select the patient.
And do you have data on the different products?
For example, this is a novel way of generating a CAR.
And do you know if all the CARs are similar in terms of the number of vector
insertions, what those ranges are, or were the
responders more transformed or had fewer vectors, things like that?
Sorry, we don't have this data.
Any other questions from the
audience?
Excellent. Well, thank you very much.
It's really a fascinating way to generate a CAR, and I think a fascinating early
data.
So next up, I'd like to invite Dr. Rhodabe Amaria, who's
going to give us results of a first-in-human Phase 1 study of
KSQ001EX, an autologous tumor-infiltrating lymphocyte
therapy engineered to inactivate SOX1 gene in patients with
selected solid tumors.
Hi. Hello, my name's Rhoda Amaria from MD Anderson.
On behalf of my co-authors, I'm honored to be here today to discuss the results
of the first-in-human study of KSQ001EX.
My disclosures are shown here.
So the key takeaways from this presentation is that
KSQ001EX is an engineered TIL cell
therapy using CRISPR-Cas9 editing to remove the gene
SOX1 from T cells. The
SOX1 is a negative regulator of
cytokine signaling and T cell functioning.
This TIL therapy was very well tolerated with no high-grade
dose limiting toxicities, and we see preliminary evidence of anti-tumor
efficacy with cell doses of one to 10 billion with or
without IL-2. This dosing is far lower than what's traditionally
used with unmodified TIL.
We also see evidence of SOX1 inactivation
with these TIL being able to expand and proliferate in the peripheral
blood and reinvigorate the tumor microenvironment with a CD8
cytotoxic state.
Patients with metastatic melanoma that are resistant or refractory
to immune checkpoint inhibitor have poor prognosis, then
are in need of novel treatment options.
There is FDA approval for an autologous TIL cell therapy for this
patient population, but this is associated with a dose of 7.5 to
72 billion TIL with up to six doses of high-dose IL-2.
Attempts at using TIL therapy outside of melanoma have been
challenging to another solid tumors having a lot of tumor antigen
heterogeneity and immunosuppressive features within the tumor microenvironment.
In an effort to combat those challenges, genome-wide CRISPR
screens were done to try to identify features or genes
within T cells that contributed to T cell dysfunction.
SOX1 was one of the strongest targets identified in addition to
PD-1 and other targets that are used by pharma companies.
So SOX1 is a negative regulator of cytokine signaling and T cell function.
If you inactivate SOX1 in T cells, you actually allow these T
cells to engraft and persist better, to preferentially
accumulate within the tumor and lead to superior tumor killing,
and these T cells have more of a central memory phenotype.
When you edit out SOX1 from mouse models, you can see
fivefold increased
expansion of these CD8 T cells persisting in the
blood. This leads to enhanced anti-tumor activity
compared to controls. Human T cells with
SOX1 editing are associated with increased anti-tumor effects
against tumor spheroid models and a marked increase in interferon
gamma expression. Due to these pre-clinical
studies, we were convinced that SOX1 editing would lead to
better persistence and activation with these edited TIL, and
therefore, we specifically chose a dose of one to 10 billion
TIL to be used for this
study.The initial design of this clinical
trial was to have a safety lead in cohorts in melanoma with
the potential for expansion into other solid tumors.
So for the melanoma patients that were enrolled, they had to be refractory to at
least one line of PD-1 based therapy in the metastatic setting and had
to have enough disease for tumor harvest and additional disease for resist
response. Primary objectives were safety and tolerability, with
secondary objectives including ORR duration of
response. The initial cohort of metastatic melanoma patients were treated
between one and 10 billion KSQ001EX cells
and no IL-2. And then there was a second safety lead-in cohort,
metastatic melanoma, one to 10 billion TIL and up to six
doses of high-dose IL-2.
Patients enrolled in this clinical trial had
tumor resection or
multiple core needle biopsies as a starting
material for TIL growth.
Patients were treated with standard doses of lymph
depletion, including cyclophosphamide, 60 milligram per kilogram for two days,
and fludarabine, 25 milligrams per meter square for five days,
followed by a single KSQ001EX infusion, and then
up to six doses of high-dose IL-2 just for the cohort two patients.
DLT assessment period was 28 days, and then patients were followed
routinely for imaging for resist response.
This manufacturing is called the EXPRESS program,
which is a proprietary engineered manufacturing process,
which is a 22-day PBMC feeder-free
environment. TIL are extracted from the tumor
starting material in 11 days or less, followed by CRISPR-Cas9
engineering, and then another 11 days or less for TIL expansion.
This leads to drug product that is highly
efficient in terms of the CRISPR editing, 95%,
and the infusion product is predominantly a CD8,
CD27 positive young TIL phenotype.
Further details about this novel manufacturing can be seen in the poster
presentation tomorrow.
A total of 15 patients underwent tumor harvest.
There were two manufacturing failures and three patients that generated
less than a billion cells, with two of those three patients that were able to be
treated. So a total of 12 patients were included in the safety
analysis. Median age was 46.5 years.
Most patients had BRAF mutations, and
median previous lines of therapy were two, with a range of one to five.
Forty-two percent of patients had elevated LDH, and the median
KSQ001EX cell dose was 5.25 billion
cells.
This regimen was well-tolerated with really majority of
toxicities related to the effects of the lymph depleting
chemotherapy. There was no dose limiting toxicities, there was no
CRS, ICANS, or any obvious SOX1 specific toxicities,
and no Grade 5 events.
Here we see the efficacy for the 10 patients that were treated between one and 10
billion TILs. The first
row shows the cell dose, second, number of IL-2 doses specific to
the cohort two patients, and then we see the waterfall plot of response and
durability. If we focus specifically on the patients treated to
the right of this orange line, these are the
patients that received over the median 5.25 billion cell dose.
We can see 100% of those patients experienced some tumor reduction with an
ORR of 33%, including one patient with prolonged PR
over 12 months.
We can see that these KSQ001EX cells
have the ability to engraft and expand in the blood over time.
This is most notable for the patients treated over the 5.25 billion
cells and can be seen when the product was given with
IL-2, as shown in orange, or without IL-2, as shown in
blue. We do see that these cells are able to persist out over
several weeks
to even months in patients treated over the
5.25 billion.
Preclinical data had suggested potential for marked increase in
interferon gamma levels, and indeed, we saw this in our treated patients
independent of use of IL-2. And the interferon gamma peaks were
significantly higher than what's been reported in the literature with unmodified
TIL.
Here we see a case study of a patient who received 8.4
billion TIL and had prolonged stable disease for over 12 months.
We see in orange the
KSQ001EX over time with persistence out to
500 days. And in turquoise, you see interferon gamma, which
peaked
prior to the
engineered TIL expansion, suggesting cognate tumor antigen
recognition indicative of the SOX1 biology.
We performed day 28 biopsies on treated patients, and we can see
remodeling of the tumor microenvironment, and specifically
20% of the
T cells in the tumor sample were
KSQ001EX. Single cell sequencing was
done on tumor starting material, the drug product in the day 28
biopsy, and we can see remodeling of the tumor microenvironment at day
28 to be enriched for CD8 positive T cells with high
cytotoxicity compared to the tumor starting material.
So to conclude, KSQ001EX is a
CRISPR-edited SOX1-inactivated TIL.
This manufacturing leads to a favorable drug product enriched
for CD8 positive, CD27 positive young TIL.
This regimen is safe and well-tolerated with no dose limiting
toxicities and most AEs attributable to the lymph
depletion. We do see dose-dependent target lesion
reductions with better efficacy in patients treated above
the median cell dose. We do see ability of these cells to
expand and persist in the blood over time, with or without
IL-2, and we can see that these cells have the ability to infiltrate the
tumor and remodulate the tumor microenvironment into a CD8 positive
cytotoxic state.This current clinical trial has
closed enrollment, and we have now moved on to a second
trial with a dual edit of SOX1 and RAG1.
This is currently in a dose escalation in melanoma patients at
MD Anderson, with plans to move into dose expansion
cohorts in multiple solid tumors and to expand to a multicenter study.
I'd like to thank all the patients and their caregivers for participating in this
trial, as well as our clinical team and translational team at MD
Anderson and our manufacturers at the CTMC.
Thank you so much for your attention today.
Thank you so much for that great presentation. I'll start the questions.
I was looking at your
background, and I was thinking to myself that this is going to be a way to avoid
IL-2, that we could have TILs as an outpatient therapy.
But when I look at the data, the IL-2 treated patients did seem to do slightly
better on your
curves, but at the same time, it was also higher dose patients.
So is the issue really that we need more cells or low
cell numbers need IL-2, higher cells can do without? What's the dynamics here?
That's a great question. I think the bottom line is we need more cells.
I think the translational data is pretty consistent that the IL-2 might
help with an initial expansion, but actually even in the group
without IL-2, they expanded and persisted just fine.
So I really think it's more of a cell dose
situation. But absolutely, this could potentially be an
outpatient regimen if using lower doses of lymph depletion.
And again, I'm not sure we actually need IL-2 in this situation.
And was the low dose intentional or is doing this process make TIL
manufacturing more challenging?
It's a good question. I think based on the preclinical data, there really was
concern that these edited TIL would be a bit more potent
than unmodified TIL, and so specifically that lower
dose range was chosen. It's not a manufacturing
issue.
The manufacturers can produce more cells than this.
Excellent. Thank you.
Yeah. And what are the location of
the non-targetation that
achieved a complete response in the two patients?
What's the location?
Oh, yeah. These people had widely metastatic disease, so
locations could be liver, lung, lymph nodes. I'm not entirely certain.
Yeah, I can't remember. But these people all had widely metastatic melanoma.
Any questions from the audience?
All right. Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
A fascinating innovation in TIL therapy.
I'd like to invite Dr. Paul Nathan up.
He's going to give us a five-year survival of Tebentafusp.
I will eventually, in my career, be able to pronounce this drug.
Tebentafusp in previously treated uveal melanoma from the Phase III trial.
Thank you. On behalf of my collaborators,
co-investigators, I'd like to thank the AACR committee,
for the opportunity to present
five-year survival results from this Phase III study with
Tebentafusp in previously untreated metastatic uveal
melanoma.
These are my disclosures.
So the IMC GP100-202 study
represented two very important firsts.
It was the first positive Phase III study in metastatic uveal
melanoma, which is a refractory disease and distinct from
cutaneous melanoma.
And it was the first T-cell receptor therapeutic to demonstrate a
survival benefit. So Tebentafusp is a bispecific
soluble T-cell receptor therapeutic.
It's an affinity-enhanced T-cell receptor, specific
for a GP100 peptide, which is presented in the context of HLA,
and it's fused to an anti-CD3-FE.
It's designed to redirect T-cells in the microenvironment to
GP100-positive melanocytic cells.
And the key question with this novel agent was whether
or not it resulted in durable responses
due to this non-specific recruitment of T-cells in the
tumor microenvironment.
The 202 study was performed in advanced uveal
melanoma. Patients needed to be HLA-A0201 positive.
It was a first-line study.
And the randomization was 2:1 of Tebentafusp versus
investigator's choice of either Pembrolizumab, Ipilimumab, or
Dacarbazine. 82% of patients had Pembrolizumab.
We reported the primary analysis in 2021, which showed
a hazard ratio of 0.51
in favor of Tebentafusp.
The safety was reported or updated at the three-year landmark,
and today I'm going to present to you the five-year minimum
follow-up.
So here are the Kaplan-Meier curves.
You can see there was early separation of Tebentafusp
from the investigator's choice curves, and that has been maintained
throughout the duration of the study.
The hazard ratio for overall survival for these curves is
0.67.
And at the five-year landmark, there's a doubling of
overall survival from 8% to 16%.
Of particular note,
44% of the patients randomized to receive Tebentafusp
only received Tebentafusp,
and 86% of the five-year survivors
on the investigator choice arm did in fact cross over to receive
Tebentafusp at a later date.
The Tebentafusp overall survival benefit was maintained when the effects of
subsequent therapy was
removed.Here is overall survival in key
subgroups, and there was a benefit or a trend to benefit in
favor of Tebentafusp in the great majority of these subgroups.
Specifically, I draw your attention to the fact that there was benefit
seen in patients with a normal LDH or a raised LDH,
or with small, intermediate, or large volume disease.
And for those of you who are not familiar with uveal melanoma, it's a very
hepatotropic disease.
95% of patients on this study presented with hepatic disease,
and we could see benefit
whether or not there was disease restricted to the liver
or in the liver, and also extrahepatic
sites.
Now, many of you may be familiar that the radiographic
assessment of Tebentafusp is not the most sensitive indicator of
overall survival benefit. There is
certainly an improved RECIST response rate in
Tebentafusp compared to investigator's choice, 46% disease
control rate compared to 27% control rate.
But it's when one looks at the progressive disease
patients, those patients whose best overall response was progressive disease,
one can see the frailty of radiographic
response in detecting survival benefit.
So if you just look at these patients whose best overall response was progressive
disease,
you can see patients randomized to receive Tebentafusp did substantially
better than those randomized to investigator's choice, with a hazard ratio on these
curves of 0.61.
ctDNA response is a more
sensitive indicator of benefit from overall survival.
So on this study, patients had blood taken for baseline
ctDNA, and baseline ctDNA was detected in
61% of patients. So there were nearly 40% of
patients with macroscopic disease at baseline who did not have
detectable ctDNA, and we'll come onto those on the next slide.
So of these
61% of patients who had baseline detectable ctDNA,
you can see here, overall, there was a molecular response rate of
81%. These responses were assessed at the week nine time
point, and at week nine, 37% of patients had
cleared their ctDNA. Another 44% had had a
greater than 50% reduction, leaving this 81%
molecular response rate.
So if you look at how the ctDNA response is performed according to the
RECIST criteria,
in the partial response radiological group,
64% of patients cleared their ctDNA, and there was a
93% molecular response rate.
In the RECIST stable disease group,
44% cleared their ctDNA, and there was an 86% molecular
response rate. And if one looked at the subgroup within this stable
disease group who had experienced any tumor
reduction or some tumor reduction that was not great enough to reach partial
response, they did just as well as the partial responders.
The message being that any tumor reduction,
sorry, any reduction of ctDNA results in
benefit.
And then finally, this progressive disease group,
27% had clearance of their ctDNA with a
75% molecular response rate. And of note,
when one looks at the
five-year survival patients in the Tebentafusp arm,
all of those patients either had no detectable ctDNA at
baseline, or they had achieved clearance of their ctDNA.
So let's just go back to this baseline ctDNA, that there is a
difference in outcome between patients who had detectable ctDNA
and undetectable. The undetectable patients did better, and that's a
familiar story now in solid tumor oncology with a hazard ratio of
0.5. If you look at the patients
who cleared their ctDNA, they did substantially better
than those patients who did not clear their ctDNA with a hazard ratio
of 0.32. And if you look at the medians, the patients who
cleared their ctDNA, median survival of 29 months, these look very
similar to those patients who had undetectable ctDNA at baseline.
So if you can get rid of that ctDNA at nine weeks, you do just as well as if you
didn't have detected ctDNA at baseline.
And then finally, if you look at the ctDNA molecular response criteria, you can
see there's a significant, well, I should say, a
substantial survival benefit
in favor of those patients who had a molecular response with greater than
50% reduction in ctDNA and a hazard ratio of 0.41.
So the message is that ctDNA is a more robust
indicator of survival benefit than radiographic response.
Now in the protocol, we did treat patients beyond
radiographic progression,
and these spider plots
illustrate the patients who were treated beyond progression, and they are
normalized for the point that progression happened.
So if you look at these curves, you can see that following the point of progression
in these patients who had treatment beyond progression,
significant number of patients had some tumor reduction.
In fact, 27% of patients
treated beyond progression had some post-radiographic
reduction beyond the point of progression.
Very few patients on the investigator's choice arm were treated beyond progression,
and there was only a single patient whose disease reduced post
the
point of progression.Now,
when one looks at those patients who are treated beyond progression,
there's a potential selection bias because those patients tended to
have favorable baseline characteristics.
So a Cox
stepwise selection model was performed to adjust for those
covariates, and
tobentafusp still came out
as being an important factor in the survival benefit for
those patients treated beyond progression, even when those baseline
covariates were taken into account.
Hazard ratio at that point was 0.61 for the adjusted
analysis.
So in conclusion,
this study with tobentafusp is the longest follow-up for any bispecific
T-cell engager in a solid tumor, and it's the first time that
a five-year phase three analysis has been presented in metastatic uveal
melanoma. It shows early and continued separation of the overall
survival curves and a doubling of survival at the five-year time
point from 8% to 16%.
The overall survival benefit observed in these first-line
patients was very predominantly due to tobentafusp rather than subsequent
therapies.
On the tobentafusp arm, nearly half of the patients had only received
tobentafusp, and the five-year survivors on the investigator's choice arm,
86% of them had actually received subsequent tobentafusp.
The overall survival favored tobentafusp across most patient subgroups,
with benefit observed regardless of disease location or baseline
metastatic tumor size.
Early ctDNA molecular response continues to be a more sensitive marker
of tobentafusp activity than radiographic measurements.
And patients who continued tobentafusp beyond initial radiographic progression
experienced longer post-progression survival compared to those who stopped
treatment, even when accounting for
variations in baseline characteristics.
Finally, we'd like to thank all patients, their families, and their
carers, as well as all investigators and their teams who
participated in this practice-changing international trial.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Guess I'll start. I'm struck by the dynamics of the ctDNA here.
It almost looks like a peptide tumor marker, like a CEA or a
CA19-9, where significant number of patients, it's
non-contributory. When there's a trajectory, it's helpful, but it's
clearing when patients still have active disease.
So how are we supposed to use ctDNA in this setting? Is it an assay problem?
Do we have better modern assays we should be checking out on everyone and always
treating beyond progression? What does this mean for us clinically?
Yeah, I think that's a really good question.
Of course, obviously, there's no companion diagnostic with
tobentafusp.
I think the data support the use of
ctDNA in two places. The first is when you are having a discussion
with the patients initially at baseline.
Because if somebody's got undetectable disease at baseline, you know that
their prognosis,
undetectable ctDNA at baseline, you know that their prognosis
is superior to patients
untreated who have detectable ctDNA at baseline.
The second question is, can you tell with confidence those
patients who are likely to have a survival benefit from tobentafusp?
And if you see a normalization
or a reduction in fact
of ctDNA at week nine, you can look your patient in
the eye and say, "Yes, we've got some evidence that
the tobentafusp is having a desirable effect on
that patient's disease."
I think where there
are more difficulties is using ctDNA as a
guide to when you should stop treatment beyond progression,
and we haven't got a good, robust handle on a
biomarker that allows us to do that at the moment.
Looking at those spider plots, it's hard to imagine stopping at progression.
Am I missing something from how that's being reported out?
Well,
I only showed you the spider plots of people who did treat beyond
progression. Of course, you haven't seen the spider plots of all the people who
didn't go on to that point, and obviously, they didn't have treatment beyond
progression for good reason, because the kinetics of their tumors were-- yeah.
We have some questions from the audience. We'll start on the right side.
Thank you. Fantastic talk. That question actually cued up sort of
mine.
So you're looking at the radiographic imaging, and
particularly in these T-cell therapies, the question of whether we're seeing
radiologic progression versus pseudoprogression is
a
very difficult issue,
particularly when dealing with patients.
So one, sort of how was that call made for this study,
and two, do you see ctDNA being a
helpful adjunct for the radiologists in the future when they're making this
call, "This is real progression. This is pseudoprogression"?
Yeah. So pseudoprogression is a particular thing,
obviously defined best with immune checkpoint inhibitors.
I'm personally not convinced we see true
pseudoprogression in this disease or
with this agent. You would define pseudoprogression by initial
growth but then shrinkage,
and that normally happens quite quickly.
These patients who are treated beyond progression, there was quite some time
for most of those patients to be treated beyond progression.
So I think the changes we're seeing are not the same
biology as that which we're familiar with with immune checkpoint inhibitors
when we think about pseudoprogression.
To answer the second part of your question, the protocol defined that we could
treat beyond progression if we felt that--
beyond progression on
using RECIST 1.1, if we felt that it was in the patient's interest
to do so. But if on aSecond
radiological imaging, there was confirmed
second RECIST progression. At that point, patients
were removed from treatment. Their treatment was stopped.
I think in clinical practice, it is difficult,
and we see differing kinetics of tumor
growth in uveal melanoma. Historically, obviously, many of these patients had
very rapid progression, but there's no doubt that there are a group of
patients who, particularly with small volume disease, who have very
slow tumor progression. And it's difficult
to mandate stopping patients
who are having some slow progression of small volume disease post-progression,
particularly when one sees data like this, which implies
that there's an advantage to them.
I think if you've got very large volume disease, and you're
progressing sequentially on scans, then it's
difficult to argue that one would continue treatment under that point.
So these are subjective decisions by the physicians, and we don't have a
robust biomarker to be able to give guidance to everybody about when
to stop.
Thank you.
We have a question on the left as well.
Yeah. So another question on ctDNA.
So the trend of ctDNA outperforming
RECIST assessments for immunotherapies has been seen in other studies
too, but I would argue this is really remarkable.
And at least,
I haven't seen this level of molecular responses
in patients with progressive disease and even stable disease.
So do you have any insights or even can speculate whether this is
something to do with the uveal melanoma as a disease or the
T-cell mimetic mechanism of action, or do you think this is
generalizable, and we just haven't had such a large study
to look at before?
Yeah, I think that is a good question.
There's no doubt that the biology of uveal melanoma is obviously distinct and more
refractory to responses. In fact--
But of course, there's no way of knowing
what's caused by disease biology and what's caused by the intervention with
this study.
There are some
emerging data that imply durable
longer-term mechanisms
of exposure to tebentafusp that may change the tumor
microenvironment in a way that doesn't result
in cytoreduction but does result in an
amelioration of disease progression.
So,
the Paris group have showed that there's epitopes spreading,
and so you can imply that there's an induction of
more tumor-specific
longer-term immune responses.
And there's a postmortem study
led by Sam Turilich's group at the
Crick
where we have seen a greater
immune infiltrate from patient
samples who have died, who had previous tebentafusp a couple of years
before, and there was still a different tumor
microenvironment in those patients compared to that which we would
normally see from uveal melanoma.
So doesn't quite answer your question, but it does
raise the possibility of the fact
that radiological responses for this disease are
really not
linked to the overall survival benefit in a meaningful way.
So
I'm trying to figure out from what you're saying here, is this a disease effect, a
drug effect? We don't necessarily have it from tarlatamab, for example,
yet to see if there's similar problems.
But this doesn't look like other immune therapies in the
outcome. Radiographically, ctDNA, the kappa
myra curves, which doesn't really plateau the way a checkpoint inhibitor does, and
it's not a checkpoint inhibitor. What are we seeing here that's so
unlike other diseases and treatments?
Yeah.
What's the contributor? The disease, the treatment, or both?
Sure. So
I think the next couple of years we'll be able to answer that question a bit more
directly because we'll have
greater data from cutaneous melanoma
with IMtaX, which would say a little bit in comparison
about the shape of those curves. But I do think
there's
absolutely something very distinct about uveal melanoma,
because we haven't seen durable long-term
benefits
in uveal melanoma with anything.
And if you look at immune checkpoint inhibitors in uveal melanoma, and
I showed you the pembro data, but in fact, the ipi/nivo
data is broadly similar, and there is no
evidence for long-term benefit with ipi/nivo in uveal
melanoma. That points to the fact that the biology of this disease is very
different. Now, we know that there's a lot of
M2 macrophages in there. We know that CD4/CD8
ratios are unfavorable,
and it's hepatotropic. So there are multiple things about the biology of this
disease that make it refractory to many interventions.
The fact that we're presenting here five-year survival
data for uveal melanoma is actually remarkable.
And before we had any of this, the five-year survival for uveal
melanoma was 5% or under.
Excellent. Thank you.
Yeah. How about the patients use
this compound combined with
another treatment after progression?
Yeah, absolutely. That would be very-- And there's a whole long list, you can
imagine, of potential candidates to pair up with tebentafusp,
and various investigators are doing that at the moment.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.So next up we have Dr.
Yoonjun Kim.
Sorry.
Who will be talking to us about a Phase 1b/2a open label
multi-center randomized dose escalation study evaluating the safety,
tolerability, and efficacy of RZ001 in combination with
velganclivir and atezolizumab bevacizumab in patients with HCC.
Thank you, Chairman. My name is Yoonjun Kim,
hepatologist from Seoul National University Hospital, and
this is my disclosure.
This study is Phase 1b/2a open label multi-center
randomized dose escalation study,
and primary objectives
is safety, tolerability, and efficacy.
And primary endpoint is objective response rate.
RZ001 is an adenovirus-mediated transsplicing
ribozyme targeting and replacing Htert mRNA,
designed to selectively induce a toxic gene expression in
hepatocellular carcinoma cells.
Telomerase activity is detected in more than 80%
of cancers but is limited in normal hepatocytes,
supporting tumor selective targeting in hepatocellular carcinoma.
Despite recent advances, ICI based
therapies in HCC still show limited
efficacy with objective response rate of approximately
20% to 30%, indicating a substantial unmet need.
RZ001 is administered by an intratumoral
injection and selectively target Htert expressing
tumor cells utilizing the HSV thymidine
kinase ganciclovir suicide gene system, leading to
GCV3 phosphate-mediated DNA replication inhibition and
tumor cell apoptosis. In preclinical models,
RZ001 increased CD4 positive, CD8 positive
T cell infiltration and granzyme B expression, and
down-regulate VEGF, suggesting modulation of the tumor
microenvironment.
Addition of RZ001 to atezolizumab plus
bevacizumab showed decreased tumor growth in mouse models,
supporting the potential rationale for combination therapy in
hepatocellular carcinoma.
Let me introduce a platform technology.
RNA replacement enzyme is based on
tetrahema group intron, which has specificity by
specific RNA sensing riboswitch, as well as
efficacy by dual function of RNA cleavage and
transgene induction.
Transsplicing ribozyme with therapeutic RNA
bind to disease specific RNA, which
is Htert in this study,
and cleaves it
and transplacing chimeric RNA,
which has therapeutic efficacy.
To optimize this reaction,
target size in the RNA is screened using RNA mapping
technology,
followed by structural modification to enhance
efficacy and selectivity.
This is structure of adenovirus RZ001,
and this slide shows how RZ001 is working in
hepatocellular carcinoma.
After intratumoral injection, RZ001
specifically down-regulate Htert in cancer cells,
as well simultaneously increase expression
of HSV thymidine kinase. In the presence of
ganciclovir, it induce cell apoptosis and
necrosis.
More importantly, it induce immune cell infiltration and
T effector cell population increase and bystander effect.
This provides strong rationale for combination
of RZ001 with immune checkpoint
inhibitors.
This slide shows study schema.
The patients receive one dose of RZ001
by intratumoral injection on day one, followed by
velganciclovir from day two to 22,
and atezolizumab plus bevacizumab every three weeks for
up to two years.
And 15 subjects will be enrolled in each of the three cohorts.
Each cohort start with three patients
safety learning.
After confirming safety,
the
study proceed to next dose and
randomization is opened. And primary endpoint
was safety, tolerability,
target lesion change per RECIST 1.1 and
mRECIST. And immunologic activity are further evaluated,
including tumor response and explorative biomarkers such
as CD8 positive T cells, T regulatory T effector ratio and
TCIT. And the study followed the combination
study expansion and study dose escalation
design.
These are key eligibility criteria.
Inclusion criteria,
histological confirmed unresectable hepatocellular carcinoma with
no prior systemic therapy,
and refractory or unsuitable for TACE.
And
all tumors confirmed positive Htert expression in tumor tissue
by RNA scope assay, and the patients
belong to BCL stage B or C. And these are exclusion
criteria.This slide shows
demographics. Median age was around 68,
and most of them are male. And ECOG performance
status zero accounts for 77% for patients,
and BCL stage C account for about 23%,
while BCL stage B account for 77%.
And 62% of patients have HBV positivity,
and all tumor express HTERT.
So let move on to safety.
All patients experience at least one TAA,
such as pyrexia, hypotension, headache, pruritus, and
anemia, and
all the adverse event are easily manageable.
Grade 3 or higher TAAs occurred in
53% of patients.
All grade 3 TAEs were observed in 53%
of patients, and four grade 3 or higher
TLAs were observed.
However, no grade 4 or 5 TLAs occurred,
and no DLT was observed.
Let's looking more closely
at result, the safety result.
Here you can see we observed four grade 3
TAE, but there are no grade 4 or grade 5
TLAs. And we observed one
serious adverse event, however, there is no adverse
event leading to RG001 dose modification or
permanent discontinuation.
So this slide shows preliminary efficacy.
Objective response was about 40% by RECIST
1.1 or
61.5% by
modified RECIST.
And this waterfall plot shows best percentage change
in target lesion size from baseline.
And here you can see,
some of patient experience deep response, more than 50%.
So this slide shows time to first response and duration of
response. And
first response was observed
early at the initiation of treatment, and
this seamless flow shows quite long duration of
response, and many response is ongoing at the time of
data cutoff.
So in conclusion, RG001 represent a
first-in-class RNA transsplicing therapeutic
that enables tumor-selective gene replacement, targeting
HTERT-expressing cancer cells.
In this ongoing Phase 1b/2a study,
RG001, in combination with velganclovir
and atezolizumab bevacizumab, demonstrated favorable safety
profile with no dose-limiting toxicities,
encouraging antitumor activity, including complete responses.
More importantly, complete responses were observed in early
cohorts, along with rapid and durable responses.
This finding support a novel dual mechanism of action,
combining direct tumor cell killing and immune activation, highlighting
the potential of RG001 to enhance the efficacy of
standard immunotherapy in hepatocellular carcinoma, and further clinical
evaluation is ongoing. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you very much.
We have a question on the right side.
Yeah. The ganciclovir will most likely also shut down the virus
replication. Isn't it a little bit early to give it on day two?
Is that based on preclinical studies or...?
Yes, that's very good question. This is
non-replicating virus, and
we
give virus only one day
and simultaneously give
atezolizumab bevacizumab for two years.
The plan is for two years, and velganclovir administered
from day 2 and 22.
So a question about the target, the TERT.
Is that something that must be confirmed on biopsy?
Because in the United States, frequently we treat HCC without a biopsy.
So if we have a biomarker that we have to be targeting, can we get that from a
liquid biopsy or some other assay, or is it just so universally expressed we don't
need to?
We didn't biopsy the
target lesion after the intratumoral injection.
So we don't know.
How about this monotherapy?
Monotherapy.
Yes.
We didn't include monotherapy. This is a very early phase study,
and
that's very good question. We definitely need a control arm
to evaluate the contribution of
RG001 to the atezolizumab bevacizumab.
But
in this very early phase study, we just want to know the
safety and tolerability, and we want
to know feasibility of integration of
this RG001 to clinically relevant
backbone study.
But we believe we detect very early signal of
efficacy, so we will move on to the next
phase study.
Thank you.
It certainly looks better than atezolizumab bevacizumab, but I'm compelled to
wonder if that's the best treatment backbone.
Would it be well suited with, for example, tremelimumab and durvalumab with
a more potent immune therapy, with
CTLA-4?
Oh,
at theAt the time point of study, the only
available isi study, isi
regimen is atezolizumab/bevacizumab.
Now it is available, the opdivo/nabo and the
velmut nimotuzumab is available. At that time, it was not available.
Okay. It'd be interesting to see if at some point we can repeat that.
Perfect. Well, thank you very much for an excellent presentation.
So, we're going to continue down the story with viruses.
So we're going to next invite up Dr.
Angelica Laskog to give us a discussion of a Phase 1/2
trial evaluating LOAD-703 in combination with
nab-paclitaxel, gemcitabine, and atezolizumab in advanced pancreatic
cancer. Thank you very much.
So, hello everyone. I would like to thank
you for the opportunity to come here and present our data in
pancreatic cancer.
And here are my disclosures.
So, the aim of TME gene engineering
is to transfer immunostimulatory genes into the tumor
microenvironment, and this is to create a
Th1 type of inflammation that in turn will lead to
an in vivo expansion of tumor-reactive T cells.
So for this purpose, we created the LOAD platform, and
this is an adenovirus serotype 5/35 gene vector.
It can replicate to cause oncolysis in tumor
cells, but importantly, it contains a transgene
cassette that is located in the end of the virus
genome and driven by a CMV promoter.
And this means that the transgene expression can occur
both in tumor cells but also in other cell types in the
tumor microenvironment.
LOAD-703 is the first vector to be tested in
patients from this platform, and a LOAD
transgene cassette expresses a trimerized
membrane-bound CD40 ligand and also a
4-1BB ligand.
So these type of treatments are commonly given as an intratumoral
injection, and when you do so, CD40 ligand and
4-1BB ligand will be expressed in the tumor microenvironment.
And this will lead to activation of dendritic cells and
importantly, making them express CCR7, that
makes them migrate to lymph nodes where they can start a systemic
immune response.
At the same time, 4-1BB ligand can also act
locally directly on T cells in the tumor microenvironment
to promote their expansion and also memory formation.
But CD40 receptor is present on many different
cell types in the tumor microenvironment, and these
cells can also react to CD40 ligand stimuli.
For example, we see upregulation of receptors for T cell
transmigration from blood vessel into the tumor
microenvironment. We can see an M2 to M1
differentiation of macrophages and also a
downregulation of different tumor-promoting
factors such as TGF-beta, collagen, and fibroblast
growth factor.
So we have been focusing on pancreatic cancer, and you know this is
a cancer with a very dismal prognosis.
And they are commonly treated first line with different chemotherapies
depending on their health status and age.
And it is an immunotherapy-resistant tumor with
low number of tumor-infiltrating T cells, but a high
level of myeloid cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And these are causing a very immunosuppressive
microenvironment. But given the mechanism of action of
LOAD-703, we thought that we might be able to do
something about
the tumor milieu in these patients.
So we have been focusing on patients that receive gemcitabine
and nab-paclitaxel,
given first line, second line, or at any line as long as they can
get these two chemotherapies.
We have some previous experience with LOAD-703 in
different clinical trials. It has been evaluated in melanoma, for
example, together with checkpoints and in different
pancreatic cancer studies and a few patients with different
solid tumors.
And the study I will present today is LUCON-001,
and it's actually a two-armed study, and it's the second arm we will
focus on, but I will give you a brief introduction to arm
one as well. So we enroll patients
with advanced pancreatic cancer, and they receive LOAD-703
together with gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel.
The LOAD-703 dose was escalated in three different
dose levels against a fixed dose of chemotherapy.
We enrolled 18 patients in arm one.
Fifteen of them had stage four disease, and half of the
patients were first line.
The overall response rate across dose levels was
44% in this arm,
and the overall survival was 9.3 months in this rather
heterogeneous group of patients.
In this study, we also confirmed that we had activation
of CD8 positive T cells, and it was especially the
effector memory population that was increased in blood,
and these cells could react to a number of different
tumor-associated
antigens.In tumors, we can see
a massive upregulation of different immune biomarkers that
are related to a T cell response. And in this string
analysis, we can also see that it's a CD40-dependent
TH1 immune activation that seems to be ongoing.
So coming now to LuCON 001 arm two. Now,
when we know that we have expanded T cells in these patients,
we thought, what if we add atezolizumab, which is an
anti-PD-L1 antibody, to this combination?
And in this study, LOAD 703 is given every other
week, as you can see below, and
chemotherapy is given the usual day one,
eight, and 15 in a 28-day cycle.
Atezolizumab was given the first day of each
chemotherapy cycle, so every fourth week.
Also here, patients with advanced pancreatic cancer at
any line of treatment were enrolled, as long as they were
eligible for gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel.
We took the two highest dose levels to test in this triplet
combination and enrolled 24 patients, 12
patients per dose level. Twenty-two of the patients had
stage four disease, and 13 were treated first
line.
So of course, these patients had all the different adverse
events that are related to chemotherapy.
But considering LOAD 703,
this didn't add so much to the patients other than fever,
chills, fatigues, which is kind of expected if you inject
a virus into the body.
We did see some kidney-related toxicity that
was possibly attributed to our virus, but
also to atezolizumab or even chemotherapy.
In this patient, again, we could see the massive upregulation
of adaptive response biomarkers.
And in particular, it was markers related to T
cell activation. But we could also see some
biomarkers that were decreased in these patients after treatment
initiation, and those were biomarkers of fibroblast
proliferation and acute inflammation.
We could confirm that we had CD8 positive effector
memory T cells that increased in blood
and T regulatory cells that were
downregulated in these patients.
So the overall response rate in arm two was
38% across dose levels, but we did
see three complete responses in these patients.
All of the patients that had complete responses had stage
four disease, so with liver metastasis.
All three had prior surgery with either gemcitabine
and nab-paclitaxel or folfirinox as neoadjuvant or
both neoadjuvant and adjuvant, plus or minus
radiotherapy.
They were quite durable. The first patient in complete response
was in complete response for over two years, the second one
and a half year, and the third, unfortunately, only a couple of
months.
The progression-free survival was seven months, and
overall survival 9.9 months. But
if we look then at the patients that were treated
first line,
we could see that the median overall survival was
14.7 months with a one-year survival of
62%. The two-year survival was
31%, and the PFS 11.1
months. Overall response rate, 54%.
And all of the patients that had a complete response were treated
first line. And of course, the first line
treated patients are not many. This is a small
population of 13 patients, so that's something to keep in
mind comparing this data to what we know from
chemotherapy.
But nevertheless, if we compare the survival of
arm one and arm two in this study, it surely looks like
atezolizumab is providing some
survival benefit to these patients.
But is it LOAD 703, the antibody, or both?
Obviously, we don't know that yet, and the next step is to
perform a randomized four-armed trial
to evaluate the contribution of each component.
And considering that all in all, we have treated now
74 patients with pancreatic cancer in different
trials, the next step will be also a registration
trial. So we have discussed with the FDA the design already.
So with that cliffhanger, who is responsible for
the effect we see, I will leave you to acknowledge
the patients and families and also the PI in this study,
Benjamin Mascher at Baylor College of Medicine, and also
Malcolm Brenner, who is the scientific advisor to this
project. Of course, there's a lot of people involved when you are doing a
trial, and this arm one, two study actually took
10 years. So I'm glad to be here today and
present it finally. So with that, I'm happy to take any
questions.
Thank you.
Excellent. Congratulations on a really titanic effort in pancreatic cancer, a very
hard disease.
It's notable that you saw really better responses in the
earlier line patients, and it makes me wonder about the role
ofOf this agent in neoadjuvant therapy for inoperable locally advanced
disease, is this an opportunity to convert patients to
resectable from truly unresectable? Are you investigating that?
I think it is. I think
LOAD 703 would really have great potential even
earlier stages. When we were
talking about where to begin with this study, at least we knew that we
had to have pretty healthy patients.
It is an activating immunotherapy, and pancreatic cancer is a
rapid disease, unfortunately. We had to go in early,
but we didn't dare to go that early.
But I think that's a really interesting next step.
Yeah. It's
a subset of pancreatic cancer that is neither metastatic nor curable, so it's a
great place to think about. We have a question on the right.
Hi. So I might have missed it, but how long are you able to
detect this virus after the treatment circulating in the
body?
Yeah. So it's given intratumorally, so it
doesn't really spread to
blood that much. You can detect it in blood maybe a
day after, but then neutralizing antibodies will
remove any virus that are circulating in blood.
And in the tumor,
we actually have only biopsies two weeks later,
and then we see the effects of the transgenes, but we
don't see so much of the virus anymore.
So I think in the next study, we will try to take a biopsy
earlier just to see a little bit how long it persists.
Okay. And second question is, do tumor cells
acquire any resistance mechanisms to
this virus therapy, for example, like some mutations that
disables the replication of the viruses?
Yeah. Well,
I
haven't seen any resistance to the oncolytic
effect, at least. The virus seems to replicate well.
I think the only thing to
push back on the replication would be perhaps a chemotherapy that would
disrupt the tubulin system or so, and not one
like paclitaxel that keeps it up, and maybe like
vincristine that breaks it down. But in terms
of other mechanisms, we do see that when you
stimulate
the immune system in this way, it will, of course, upregulate PD-1
and PD-L1, one of the reasons we wanted to include a
checkpoint. But something else we see is
all the patients that progress rapidly, they have a lot of
IL-6. So that would be something I would like to
block because I think that's also a kind of a resistance
mechanism.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. It's very interesting. Can you try?
I noticed the
efficacy is quite well, but
we also
find the safety profile is also very good.
Do you think this combination have a protect function?
It's a very good question.
It is a weird thing when you give the LOAD 703 virus to
patients, but
we always get the responses from the PI, like, "The patient seems
to be doing so well, and they are happy." And I'm
starting to think that maybe the immune system also will
affect how you feel in a way when you have
an immune response ongoing. But it is actually a fact that
in mice,
if you give chemotherapy, they lose weight, but they don't
when we combine it with our virus. And we cannot really
explain that yet.
So is this an opportunity to combine with Folfirinox, especially when we look at--
We know KRAS inhibitors are here. We know diraxumrasib is
potent but reasonably toxic, and the combination with Folfirinox may be
challenging. Is this a better combo with Folfirinox?
I'm not sure. Folfirinox is still four
chemos. It might
inhibit the immune system a little bit too much.
If I were to combine with something else, I think
I would like to combine it with perhaps T-cell therapy.
But I would
like if we could sort of remove the chemotherapy altogether,
if there is a way to do that, because that would really take away
a lot of the side effects that we do see from the
chemo. So that would be interesting, and maybe it works even
better if you don't have the chemotherapy there.
But you can never do that the first time you try, but
perhaps in the future.
Yeah. Although,
I don't know if Folfirinox is actually that lympholytic.
If anything, gemcitabine, which is essentially cytarabine, may actually
be harder on T-cells than ancient 5-FU.
We did a study looking what gemcitabine is
doing to these patients, and it seems to act mostly on the myeloid cell
compartment to remove the myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
It also reduced TGF-beta to really low levels.
So I think gemcitabine is actually not so bad
combination partner in that sense.
Excellent.
All right. Thank you very much.
Now we have our last presentation from Dr.
Li Wang,
presenting ABO2203, a messenger RNA encoding a
CD3/CD19 T cell engager for relapse refractory B-cell
non-Hodgkin lymphoma, preliminary results from a first-in-human study.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for the go chair and
distinguished professor and colleagues.
I'm Li Wang from Shanghai RiJin Hospital, and today
I'm pleasure to present our recent work about
ABO2203, a messenger mRNA
encoding a CD3 CD19 T cell
engager for relapsed and refractory B-cell non-Hodgkin
lymphoma. And this is my close trial
information. The protein-based T cell engager show
promise for hematological malignancies.
However, the challenge remain in safety, efficacy, and
durability. ABO2203 is a lipid
nanoparticles encapsulate messenger mRNA
encoding a CD3 CD19 TCE.
In the preclinical study, ABO2203 demonstrated
a more favorable pharmacokinetics, improved
safety, and enhanced antitumor potency compared
to protein-based TCE. And I will show this
result afterwards.
So we begin our investigator-initiated trial aim to
evaluate the safety and the efficacy of
ABO2203 for relapsed and refractory
CD19 positive B-cell non-Hodgkin lymphoma patients.
Here is a structure of mRNA encoded CD3
CD19 TCE. The left panel showed the
nanoparticles enclosed mRNA, which encoded
a single chain of CD19 CD3 and the
long circulating domain. And this long circulating domain
is to stabilize this protein.
And when the nanoparticles is
subcutaneous injected, and it was
uptake by human cells, then translate into
the TCE and secreted to the
blood. And this TCE can engage T cell with B
cell, and meanwhile, activating T cell and depleting B
cells. And this treatment without
lymphodepletion and no cell collection and also
ex vivo preparation. And the right
panel show the PK profile of ABO2203.
And the red curve show the gradual protein expression
from mRNA, provides T cell with a
natural activation process. And when
compared with post recombinant protein
TCE, and this mRNA
translate
TCE can have more
AUC area than this post TCE.
And this is the preclinical results
in murine models. And in the red curve
is the ABO2203. The AUC
area is larger than the protein TCE.
And this matched protein TCE
is P4107, which is the
protein
encoded by the
ABO2203. And in the
antitumor activities, we have
shown in the murine models the
ABO2203, even in a very
low level, 0.1
microgram
in the mouse model, it can significantly reduce the
tumor growth. And as of the cytokine
release, the IL-6, IL-10, TNF alpha,
and the interferon gamma is also lower than the
matched TCE protein.
Here is our trial design. This is phase one dose
escalation trial, and we have three cohort.
The cohort one, we begin
the three microgram to
480 microgram. And in the
cohort two, we begin with
120 microgram, and then the maximum
dose was 960 microgram. And in the
cohort three, the patient begin with 240
microgram, then the maximum microgram is
1,920
microgram. And this dose was weekly
administrated. And the primary
study endpoint was adverse events, dose
limiting toxicity, and maximum tolerated dose.
And secondary endpoint was overall response rate,
disease control rate, and also PK data.
Here is the baseline of our nine patients.
The median prior line of treatment was four, and all
patients failed from CD20 targeting therapies.
As of B and natural subtypes, three patients with follicular
lymphoma and two each with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma,
mantle cell lymphoma, and marginal zone lymphoma.
And as of the pharmacokinetic profiles,
ABO2203 produced dose as dependent
TCE expression with a peak concentration in serum
about five days and half-life of eight days.
Its slow rising PK profile led to a natural priming
of T cells enabling higher starting dose
without increased risk of CIS.
As of efficacy, across all cohort, the overall
response rate was 67% and the
DCR was 78%. And in the last week,
we evaluated our patients, and all the three patients in
high dose
achieved complete remission. So we have four complete
remission patients and achieved
44%.And
here I'd like to show our representative patients.
This patient is a young male and diagnosed with marginal zone
lymphoma since
2021. The prior treatment included
bendamustine combined with rituximab, and then relapsed, he
received zanubrutinib. And the progression
after that treatment, he received a
CHOP treatment. And this study begin with
240 microgram on day one, then the next week he
received 960 microgram. And the third
week, he received 1,920
microgram, and then this dose every week.
He reached
complete remission at week eight through PET-CT scan.
And then he had the dose every two weeks.
And the peripheral blood, we can see in the peripheral
B cell were completed the depletion within one week.
And the right panel show the lymph node at week three.
And here, the CD19 positive B cell
completely depleted in the lymph node, and with the
marked CD3 T cell infiltration in the lymph node.
As of the safety, no DLT, no SAE, and
no TAE leading to treatment discontinuation,
and no CIS, ICANS, and over Grade 1
hepatic dysfunction was found. The most common
TAE were pyrexia, and all were Grade 1 or
Grade 2. The Grade 3 or 4 TAE
occurred in three patients, including neutropenia and
blood fibrinogen decreased. And all these AE
recovered within one week.
As of the safety, the cytokine profile, we have found the
low level of interferon gamma and the IL-10 release
following initial and subsequent doses.
The IL-6 release was generally low and just two
patients with marginal zone lymphoma displayed a transient
IL-6 surge after tocilizumab treatment.
And this phenomenon was also found in CAR-T therapies,
the tocilizumab can increase the IL-6
concentration in the blood.
As the vital signs,
the ABO2203 treatment transient
body temperature elevation was observed, but all this
body temperature can decrease
by
patients. And the oxygen
saturation and blood pressure remained stable
in all of the patients.
In summary, the ABO2203 demonstrated a favorable
safety and on-target pharmacokinetics and
preliminary efficacy in these nine patients.
And our trial confirmed that mRNA-encoded
TCE is feasible and supporting it as a promising
treatment option for those refractory and relapsed
B-cell non-Hodgkin lymphomas.
And we thank all of our patients and their family and
all our teams and our colleagues for their collaborations, and
thank you for your attention.
Thank you for that excellent presentation.
That was a really cool way to deliver a bispecific
process. Does this have a different dynamics?
Are patients going to develop immunity against these?
We're going to clear them, we're going to have worse BKs with time compared to an
antibody-based process, or will this just continue to perform similarly?
Yes. In this mRNA-encoded TCE, it
also we find some patient with fever and also
a moderate increase of cytokines.
But when compared with the protein TCEs, the
fever is more higher. When post injection
with this protein, the higher fever, and also we will
have very higher CRS. And in our centers,
for some patient with bulky mass, the fever
and the CRS is more higher. And
in this nine patients, no CIS occurred.
And the patient with the fever, just
38 degree, and it can decrease
after several hours. And
the low level of cytokines. So we don't think this
fever is the CRS because the cytokines is very low, and the
CRS should have higher cytokines.
So it defined as cytokine release syndrome.
So no CIS, no ICANS, and more safe than the
protein TCE.
Question on the right.
Have you looked at any CAR T refractory patients, or do
you plan to do so?
You means when the TCE compared with CAR T?
Any patients that have been treated with CAR T and progressed.
Yes.
In these nine patients, we haven't CAR T
patient, but we haven't reported, and we will have
the expansion cohort with 10 patients.
In the expansion cohort, we have the CAR T
patients. And the CAR T patient can also responded
to this TCE because when the patient progressed
after CD19 CAR T, we will repeat
biopsy and to confirm the CD19 positive.
If the patient was CD19 positive, he will also
responded to our TCE treatment.
Hi, this is Xinxin from AstraZeneca. Really great data.
My question is for target LNP or LNP injections,
especially systemic infusion, you already see anti-PEG
ADA generated. So in this case, you are doing local
muscular injection. Do you see, after repeat
dosing for a long time, do you see anti-PEG ADA
or any anti-TCE ADA
generated?
Here, we also do some ADA detection for those
patients, and we don't find the high ADA
antibodies in these patients. Perhaps in
the expansion cohort, we will continue to
monitor the level of ADA.
I think for the more patients, we can confirm our data
if the ADA will be high or after the long
administration, the ADA will
appear or not. But now we don't find any
positive ADA in these nine patients.
For both PEG and also the TCL engager itself.
Now we detect the ADA just for
the TCL engager.
Thank you.
Hey, Shamin from Moderna Therapeutics.
Yeah, thanks for the updating of this promising
efficacy data and also control the
side effects, although like in earlier
clinical trial. So my question is,
do you have some idea which cell type in the human body actually
produce these
TCEs or maybe you have some insights from the pre-clinical model
regarding this like in 2203?
Yes. Now we are testing
the CD19 and the CD3, perhaps afterwards,
I think your recommendation is very
important for those patients if they have
CD19 negative, the CD20 and the CD3
TCE or
other CD22 to CD3
TCE is also important for those patients if
they were CD19 negative. And now, when we
compared with the protein TCE with
CD3 and
CD20 under
just this mRNA encoded TCE,
have lower
adverse events with those protein TCE.
And also, our mRNA encoding the TCE has
lower protein
molecular weight. And for this TCE, just
67 kDa. And when the protein
TCE is about 115 Da. That
means the small molecular will be more
penetrate into the tumor
inside and can have better efficacy, and
then those perhaps will have better efficacy
than those
large molecular weight.
Yeah. Thank you for the nice comparison of this mRNA encoding
the TCE versus protein-based TCE.
So I'm wondering, have you ever checked which cell type
in the human body produce this TCE?
Or maybe you have any insights from the pre-clinical model which cell
type
actually in vivo generate this TCE by their
LNP nanoparticle encoded,
encapsulated mRNA.
Thank you. It's a very important questions.
We have dissect our murals models, and because
this
nanoparticles injected the cutaneous.
So, in the adipose site and also
fibroblast cells in the subcutaneous area,
they can produce these TCEs. And
also these particles can circulate, sometimes
recirculate in the blood, and also other
cells can also produce, but the majority is by the
adipocytes and also the fibroblast
cells in the cutaneous areas.
Very nice talk. I'm Yang Ming Zhao from UTC
Therapeutics. So just a question is, based on your
current
safety and efficacy results, do you think
you raised dose level your RP2D, or
you think you can increase
the dose to get a better and deeper durable results,
still safe enough?
Yes.
Now we have the expansion
cohort with the
1,920 microgram
is the cohort three dose. We want to expand the
patient's number to confirm the safety and
also with the long administration, the patient
will also have safety. Now, the longest
patient has administrated in this trial for about
four months. And for those patient achieved complete
remission,
he will decrease the dose every two weeks.
And after two months will decrease
to one month for one dose.
So when we decrease the dose, I think, for
those patients, we didn't find any longer
adverse events in these long-term patients.
And all these adverse events was more concentrated
in
between two months.
Thank you.
All right. If we have no other questions, thank you very much.
Thank you everyone for attending this session.
It's been a really fascinating exploration of different approaches to immune
cell therapies and other delivery mechanisms into cells, into tumors
and viruses. Thanks so much.